[Musique]
comment ça je t'aimais bien deux bons
mois alors si je peux donner un conseil
je suis toujours deux c'est mieux je
gère mes parents que je vois que c'est
louise nantel et narines
soit joli ça mieux croit franchement pas
sûr
mais fish quelques jours j'ai la ferme
et j'ai appris qu'on pouvait se filmer
tous les deux regardez elle est là donc
on n'a pas la grèce pose un très fort
également ouattara c'est quoi le vide
non faut pas dire tu vois cette fois la
pression de l'europe et il m'a dit c'est
ta vie là sont pas le dire que la boule
un nom n'a pas été bon la jambe j'ai
envie de faire l'émission commence
sous une grenouillère ça gervais munger
j'aime bien les tudors avec l'édition
legacy
[Musique]
l'idée
c'est parti chez vous
m
[Applaudissements]
les changes mais ces choses à manger
regardez non mais la mairie pour dire
aussi gai ni mon petit air là qui est
juste là il ose même pas de paris vous
répondront au téléphone à voir c'est ce
qu'on m'a dit dans l'oreille gauche